on this topic uh quincy jones i read
said to odbnu when it rains get wet
what do these words mean to you
well i think what quincy was saying at
that time was
you know
i think i was more conservative
like as a person
and like you know
had money
women wanted me
anything i kind of wanted
uh
i probably could have had you know what
i mean
and he was just saying when it rains to
get wet enjoy this man it's raining on
you
you know i mean i'm gonna pick up don't
put up the umbrella don't go back in the
house yeah get wet experience the moment
yeah and enjoy it and
i didn't take total heed to him at that
time a couple of years later i took some
heat
by that time i didn't take heat and
and when i took heat
i think that i
may have misinterpreted
by looking at his example of getting wet
versus my example of getting wet
and i can tell you right now i'm getting
wet right now in my way
in part thanks to your mother but
overall you just learned how to
appreciate the rain just like the
the experience of every moment yeah and
i'll share this with you because we this
is seemed to be a very open conversation
and i haven't had this conversation so
definitely impart to my mother then
impart to my wife
i meet my wife
it's my second wife but i met her after
my mother passed
and she was just a friend you know some
girl i met thought she was beautiful
and actually built a friendship with her
but
a few years later when the relationship
became like you know this is this gonna
be my woman it was actually doing it
when i was doing the middle of my
of my divorce and i was like you know do
i run wild and hey you know man my wife
would have already filed we were
separated and
do i run wild and i didn't run wild a
little bit but not too wild right
and uh
you know i'm still a man right yeah i'm
a hip-hop guy
i read you know how to party yeah
exactly
but the funny thing is that
my wife now her name is talani
my uncle
said she
reminds me
of your mother
he knew my mother when before i knew my
mother
and he saw that and
and we ended up uh dating
um got engaged
and then her mother passes
and so now there's a total understanding
of
everything and we actually helped build
each other back up so when
so of course i have to thank my mother
for the awareness
um then i think my wife for
bringing that awareness to actual
actualization
like to actually feel
i don't think i'll be talking to you
right now and talking as much as i do
these days
if it wasn't for the security and
peace and harmony that i was able to
gain at home
you know so
and like you said you now share that
look of having to both lost here yeah
your mom
you